[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
will um start this meeting it's now the
right time
um call for any apologies
no apologies um any conflicts of
interest
no no conflicts into confirmation of
minutes
um has everybody read them
read them
you was yeah me is moved second by
councilman blackie
all in favor all right carried
matters are rising
that's good um we've got no deputation
presentations reports
um we've got a report 5.1
um colin roxborough and
um
chris freeman craig craig
cool nelly yeah
thank you so this is uh craig freeman
for you those who
may not have met him before um so he
helped put this report together with me
so that's why he's here as well
um so this report is on
the quality and compliance of the
council's water supplies for the
2019 20 period um so we get assist on
compliance if
in the same periods as our financial
years um
and we recently received the annual
compliance report from our drinking
water assessors
and we also um the report also uh
provides some information on water
quality information and complaints as
well for that same period
so in terms of compliance there's a few
different measures
that we're reporting on so the uh
compliance with the health act
compliance with the bacterial part of
the drink water standards
and the protozoa part of the standards
as well as water safety plans
and then and then as i said i also
talked about water quality and
complaints after that
so in terms of the health act this was
meant for all supplies so all um
all water suppliers have certain
obligations under the house act um
i don't think we've ever not been
assessed as meeting those
but um there was probably a little bit
more uncertainty this year with us
having water safety plans that
had um we hadn't got reapproved there
was
um one of the obligations under the
health act is to have
approved water safety plans but we were
still assessed as compliant
with the health act because we were
actively working towards
getting approved plans and were just um
in the same
position as all other councils where it
was taking longer than
usual to come up to or to for both us
and the assistance to get an
understanding of what was required
with the new water safety plan framework
so that was um
good that we were we were deemed to have
met the health act
in terms of bacterial compliance this is
achieved by
taking the required number of samples in
the
at the treatment plants and in the
distribution zone so
in the pipe work and so there's
a certain number of samples you have to
take in maximum days between
samples you have to use certain days of
the week a certain number of times
and then the samples have to be absent
of e coli
so we met this at all but one plant
early on in the compliance year there
was a sample programmed in the weekends
that wasn't taken
when it should have been and it also
wasn't picked up
soon enough that it hadn't been taken so
we didn't we lost the opportunity to um
to take an extra one because the amount
of days between samples
so that um since then because i think
that was in july
2019 we've now got a little bit more
automation where if
um someone doesn't enter the data for a
sample into the lab book then
it starts generating emails and text
messages to people
to inform them of that rather than
relying on
him you know a person to go and check
that and pick that up so
it wasn't good that we missed it but it
was um
we think we've got better systems in
place now to deal with that
um and then all all the distribution
zones we met
uh met the bacterial requirements for
all of them so took all the samples we
needed to and they were all absent of e
coli
in terms of protozoa 9 out of 12 schemes
achieve protozoal compliance waikoku
beach achieved it for the first time
because
you need to have a full 12 months 12
consecutive months from july to june
whether
treatment plant is operating so that was
the first 12 months period
where the uv plant had been operating
for the full year mandeville we would
have expected to have achieved that
but that there was one day where it
didn't and that's because the primary
well pump
failed so we had to take that pump out
we only have one primary well amanda
also that meant we used our three backup
wells
and they don't have protozoa treatment
so it's it was really
an issue around redundancy on that
scheme
where ideally we would like to you know
full redundancy in the primary world so
if one fails you can use the other one
and also um if we had more storage it
would have helped as well
um so there might have been an option to
run off storage
if we'd had more um so we do have
there have been projects in the long
term plan for a little while to address
that
they just haven't come up yet um so
we've got a new storage
uh new storage going on at mandeville
next year and we've got a
second well planned for several years
after that
um the other scheme to talk about in
terms of protozoa compliance
or two other schemes so gary maywell an
upgrade was completed that was right at
the end of june so
in terms of the july to june period it
hadn't had only operated for the last
week of that period so it couldn't be
assessed as compliant until it has a
full
until it actually operates for the full
period
um and then points road didn't achieve
it because it hasn't
had an upgrade yet so that will be um
we'll complete the project this year but
it'll need
it'll be the year after that that it
actually has operated for the full year
uh the other thing i was going to talk
about a little bit was water quality
trends so
um there's some graphs in the report on
e coli
presence levels uh both in the last year
and historically and also total
coliforms
which um so you e coli
you definitely can't have under the
standards because any e coli
as a failure to meet the standards total
color forms there's no maximum level but
they're a sign of some
some kind of insecurity in the system so
you also don't want total coliform so
they're
assessed just for monitoring and
understanding a system but not strictly
for compliance
um uh
if you look at the graphs of total
coliform's levels you
you'll see overall we had about two
percent of samples had total coliforms
present
that's a little lower than the long-term
average of 3.2 percent
um and then drilling into it a little
bit more
you can see that the main contributors
for total coliforms were cast
which is uh related to the headworks
which
we've talked about more recently so that
um
i guess it shows the value that the data
was telling us there was a problem there
and also the wood end headworks has been
a more significant
contributor of color forms than
all their other headworks as well so
we've been trying to work through
the reason for that about a year ago we
looked into we thought it was the
manganese biofilm
and the system that was almost allowing
little colonies of color forms to live
on the walls of the reservoir
so we um we've got a much better
manganese treatment filter now but we
couldn't find a direct correlation
between manganese levels
and coliform levels so then more
recently we
super coordinated the reservoirs
thinking that maybe it still had that
build up
had always been there and if we just
cleaned it off it would help
and since we've done that it has that
was only about
i think four months ago or so so we
haven't had that much data
yet but we have had one presence of
coliform since then
so not as much we used to get about 20
or 30 samples but
at the same time the problem hasn't gone
away entirely
um like we hoped it would
and we're also conscious of the fact
that back in 2012
because i've put in here a history of
e-coli events there was um
e coli and wooden that was traced back
to the head works but
i guess that that's also a sign that
there might
well back then there was definitely an
some kind of insecurity in the system
rather than just biofilm or something
like that
so what um
is noted in the report is that we want
to do more investigations that would end
because
cast is a good example of um you know
what
what can happen if you start getting
color forms there can be you know
something else can get in as well
so we're um i think the
plan is we need to do a bit more
investigation but we might come back to
council with a report
for some funding for some more extensive
sealing of the reservoir
so but the first step would be um we've
been talking to a consultant who's been
doing quite detailed assessments of
reservoirs in christchurch because
they're working really hard to prove
everything in their system is secure so
we're looking at getting the same
consultants to
do a thorough investigation of the
trinary's road reservoirs and see what
they recommend and then that would
um or may trigger us recommending
a larger project or it may be that we
can find some things we can kind of seal
up
on the spot um
so yeah i just thought i'd give a bit of
a heads up
on that and the final thing i was going
to talk about quickly on this report was
the complaint level so we've got a level
of service
to have less than five complaints per
thousand connections per year
the last three years we've gone from 8.4
to 6.4 to
20 1920 it was 3.2 so the first year
we've been
less than five um and about half the
previous year
and there's a figure showing that
breakdown by scheme
and the biggest improvement has been
would end where we used to get
quite a few complaints about the skillet
water which have almost stopped now
and also um the previous year
i think going back about two years
oxford rule number one was a big
contributor with discolored water from
the river so
i think improvements on those two
schemes is reflected in the complaint
levels as well which is good
um so that's all i was going to say on
the report so happy to take any
questions
got any questions
um uh thanks colin it's always
fascinating to uh read your reports
i see on page 35 of diligent that there
were
complaints from kaiapoi and mandeville
fernside
over the over each quarter of the year
uh that may be a different page in your
system
it's got the uh the graphs i just
wondered kaya poi as i would have
thought a very
good scheme i can understand mandeville
food site perhaps
what what was the problem or complaints
with kyle poyne
i have to be honest i don't know
specifically i think
if um if we looked at that
in terms of i guess
we would expect to see the larger
schemes represented more because there's
always
going to be some issues sometime and the
more people you have the more complaints
you'd expect so kai
for um yeah i don't know what those
complaints were off the top of my head
but i guess the level of complaints
per property is as within a normal
level for a scheme of that size i think
um
if you saw our graphs from other years
you'd see wood end
and and oxford number one completely
dominating especially if you translated
it to per connection
so it's um i'm
happy to give specific details later i
could follow up with an email or
something but i
yeah i can't tell you to talk my head
yeah
counselor becky um the alert you sent
out early it was earlier this week or
last week look tummy bug
there was no correlation with any
council supply nothing no
nothing came with that at all no we so
we actually were quite fortunate we um
we've done a lot of sampling leading up
to that just because we have to do a
certain number of saturday and sunday
samples and we'd
happen to have done the whole weekend
then so we had four or five days in a
row where it had been clear
and that had spanned the whole period
where people had got sick
but then to be extra cautious we took
on that tuesday evening we took a lot
more samples at the source the plant
articulation and from fire hydrants
surrounding the um where the illness had
been reported and they were all
good as well so um we we've talked to
community and public health and they
do say there's always a spike at this
time of year with um
in rural areas to do with farming
practices i'm not too familiar but
you know lambs and ewing and stuff like
that and
um urban areas with barbecuing and
chicken and i don't know those kind of
things so it's not
it's not unexpected to get tummy bugs
for reasons other than the water supply
but it was
just something we wanted to roll out
council barnett water outages
yes so uh well not we didn't pull that
out
uh specifically but there's a complaint
type
for loss of supply or pressure so that
is rolled into the complaints so the
issues at waikoku beach with all the
cutting out of the generator and things
have resolved yeah definitely that has
been in last
year's i think waikoku was a little bit
over represented because of that but
that hasn't
that wasn't in 1920 i think it was just
before it must have been in 1819
yeah yeah thank you and one for myself
how confident are you with the um
minimising the risk from human error
again in these samples it's not the
first time it's happened and we're
lifted it again then supposedly
yeah so we quite confident because
that's quite important for our
water plan yeah yeah we're a lot more
confident
now we've got um the last issue wasn't
july 2019 so it's been
about 18 months nearly since that
happened and we've um
yeah but it used to be a purely rely on
humans picking it up now it's um we've
got a spreadsheet where all the samples
get into the end of each day and if they
don't then they
start sending emails and texts so
there's a lot better system now
thank you um we've got a mover
councillor blackie and um
um councillor duty can't
second yet i'm sorry you're not on the
committee
no you've moved council award
been changed
i
[Music]
we got it moved by councillor blackie
seconded by council award
speak nothing speak
i picked it up
i think what this report shows to me is
that water is something we do have to
keep our finger on it's not something
you can say it's all good and do nothing
we do need to monitor it very closely as
i'm sure colin and his team does but
it highlights it's a very fragile uh
system that can very easily
tip over into a problem if we're not
careful
and i just like to thank colin for what
he's doing
and i think the report's pretty good
and we've got really good um
water in there areas so thank you
um council barnett just a quick comment
but yes i think we will have to keep a
very close eye on that
reservoir um it's historically it's
always
been issues with the manganese filter
but it's good to see the improvement in
the filter that is an excellent thing
but the reason why we've had our own
numbers
i'll put the motion all in favor against
carried right so we've got five point
term i've got
colin
up again thanks um
so this report is um about the pegasus
water treatment plant biological filter
so this is the one that now treats the
water for both pegasus
and wood end um it
presents a summary of findings from an
assessment that has recently been
carried out by gary boot
who probably most of you will know but
he um well he's
worked on most about all our water
supplies but more recently
uh he he led the project to join the
waddington pegasus schemes
and put together the proposal of
converting the
pegasus filter from a chemical one to a
biological one
and um since that's happened
he's had a really close look at the data
from it in terms of how well it's
performed
uh versus how well we thought it would
perform and
uh it has it's
fair to say it's performed a lot better
than the wooden filter so no matter what
it's a lot better than
than the previous system um the
thing and prior to wood end joining
pegasus they had been operating the
biological filter for about a year and
during that time its performance had
basically
been as good like all manganese was
below detection levels
since uh since wooden joined the flows
increased
and only in the summer months we started
to see the performance of the filter
drop
on peak days so it wasn't wasn't too
often but it was enough
to say that it wasn't performing quite
as well as we hoped because
um we know that the demand is going to
go up on that scheme
as as ravens would occur some more
growth occurs in the area
so following on from that gary had a
close look into why it wasn't
performing as well as we thought it
would um as flows increased
and there were two key reasons one was
about the depth the sand and the filters
and one was about the size of the sand
particles
themselves so the depth one filter that
had been under performing had
about 300 millimeters less sand than was
shown on the s belts
and then uh was the optimum depth
so uh that that was quite an obvious
thing it wasn't quite as we expected
um and the other thing was that the sand
size itself
um and it's that's surprising how
sensitive it is but the sand particles
average diameter was 0.6 millimeters if
the 0.9 millimeters
it's actually a lot more efficient and
um
i'd need gary here to explain all the
science behind it but it's i think it's
to do with the porosity and how much
of the manganese removing bugs can grow
in the sand and
you must be able to get a lot more bugs
depending on the specific sand
size so um and again it wasn't
it wasn't until we sampled the sand we
realized it was slightly different to
what we thought
and by contrast the wood end
filter um had the larger sand and when
it had been
performing well for its size because it
was quite small it could actually
achieve
quite a good amount of letters per
second per square meters so
it was um although overall it wasn't
performing well for its small size it
was actually able to treat quite a lot
of water
um so it that helped
that plus the pipe pilot trials and the
other research gary had done
told us that the sand particle size and
pegasus was
part of the problem um
so there's kind of a two-stage approach
taken the first stage
that we've already done is we increased
the depth of sand
in the one filter that was um 300
millimeters too low
a couple of months ago and that was
really in preparation for the summer
because there's
there's more connections now than there
was the previous summer as well so we
wanted to get that done
sooner rather than later and we've
already started to see
improvements so far so there's been
demand has just started to come up
recently the filters performed well
so far so that's good um but longer term
we are still expecting a lot more demand
in the coming years than what we
currently have
um so there's a recommendation to
at the moment we've got it in year three
of the budget to take all the sand out
and put in
the um 0.9 millimeter sand and both
filters
that cost is estimated at about 120 000
and um that will basically
sit yeah it's it's yeah it's a
well i could get a cheaper off woody
yeah
yeah so it has to be um
yeah it has to be very hygienic sand so
it's put through a drying process before
you buy it and then it's also
i can't tell you the tons without funny
in the report but it does quite a volume
um and then also the labor to actually
work inside a tree live treatment plant
one at a time and take all the other
stuff out and get the new stuff in and
super coordinate it and make it all
clean as a bit as well so we're um
we're proposing that in year three um
there's a little bit of flexibility in
that that we can continue
because we've only just done the top
half and one filter we can continue to
monitor that quality
over the summer and the next summer and
maybe it's gonna do a little better than
we think and we can push it out or
maybe we'll be chlorinating all that
water supplies
by then depending what else happens so
that would
the the reason to get better manganese
treatment is to
minimize biofilm growth and chlorine
would do the same thing so
if we were there'd be an argument that
we don't need to do this quite so soon
um but so that's why we
one reason we'd say we don't want to do
this straight away and we thought we'd
do the interim step
in the meantime um
but yeah if we are able to have an
uncoordinated supply
and if growth does happen like it's
we're expecting it to it will
be really important for the quality of
the water and the um
aesthetic parameters of the water to do
this
um it's also noted that we're collecting
um development contributions from
ravenswood which
are quite substantial and um they would
offset this because it's driven by
growth so it's not
that's why we would need to do it so um
it would be cost neutral to council to
do this um
because it's allowed for or headworks
upgrades were
part of what the development
contributions allowed for when they were
set
um so i think that's all i was going to
say in this report so happy to take me
yeah just um just before questions i
just would like to add a few comments
um on this um
and it's particularly about gary the um
this report um we're very fortunate to
have gary
uh working for us he would i would say
be
the lead expert in new zealand on
biological treatment of
water for manganese removal amongst all
of his other
skills that i know you know so well um
gary did the design and manage the
conversion of the
wood end treatment plant to a biological
process
going back a long time he won a
paper of the year award at the ipwa
conference at that time for that work so
that was recognised
when pegasus was being developed
i know i'm pretty sure most of you have
been to that plant it's an exceptionally
good plant
gary um was right right in there making
sure that
we got a good facility uh for the
council when the developer was designing
that
and at that time um it was a
chlorine-based chemical treatment
process but gary actually what through
his input
made sure it was it was designed in such
a way that we could convert it to
biological process so he's very
far-sighted in that
he then has worked with alicia fleck
who's
our one of our engineers who's just
become chartered this year
um and on on this more recent
work and it's through his mentoring and
working on this that's helped him get to
that
position um so he's converted the
pegasus
treatment plant to a biological process
um
that has given us a much better quality
of water so
uh better manganese removal
and a much more consistent dosing of
chlorine so with the drop the complaints
have been
dropped off a lot um in pegasus and just
by the way this report
that gary has written he wrote that
using eye gaze
software which he
is like a screen with a whole pile of
letters and he types by looking at
individual letters
and writing and this is uh
the feedback is most people use this for
simple yes no answers for
you know do you need me to move you that
kind of thing gary's
no one else is using that hardware and
software and he keeps pushing the limits
on and they have to keep
upgrading things um so i just really
want to acknowledge the work of gary
over
his whole career for the council but
any and he's continuing to provide us
with exceptional
work today so i um just thought it's
with making those
comments as part of this report
got any questions
uh there is um gary's done
it's a big favor and and so this he
wrote both the covering report but also
the technical report that's appended
he's got a set of steps
if it's not created in a different
slightly different set of steps over
if it is and i think um
i i actually i know that it's not as
high on the priority list i think there
would come a time
when it would be needed but it wouldn't
be as soon so
um the chlorine would deal with a lot of
the biofilm issues
but it would um it would still
as flows get higher and in the field of
performance drops more
did come a time when it would when you
would still benefit from having
better manganese removal so it would
just be a matter of timing and priority
so it wouldn't
you would still do it but you might
allow a little bit more growth to happen
before you did it
um or before it was warranted
supply that that is considered
that's there's actually the the
reticulation
has now got to a point where it's just
touching and there's a closed valve so
actually a lot of
uh ravens would like the mcdonald's in
the commercial area and then extending
up
is chlorinated and then it's it's where
it gets quite far towards woody before
it
switches to unique chlorinated
all right no more questions
counsellor just one mr chair um i'm not
a member of this committee so i can't um
move anything but i just wondered
whether you would consider in the
wrecking
in the recommendation acknowledging the
work of gary boot
um because i think it's pretty fantastic
what what he does and it would be great
to acknowledge that
okay and
[Music]
um
it cool um
support the report it's well put
together in it
certainly that this is something we need
to do so um
thank you for that i i have been to
gary's home
uh when we presented him with an award
earlier in the year
and have seen harry's use this
technology and it's amazing
um really it's um
yeah he's an amazing guy and we are so
lucky to
still have his services and it was
lovely that he could come
a few weeks seems like it was a few
weeks for maybe a month or so back
when we had the community service awards
then were able to acknowledge that
amongst
others that were also given awards but
he's an exceptional guy who's given an
amazing service
over a large number of years with water
supply upgrades when i first came onto
council
i was involved in those and colin you've
picked up some of gary's really good
practices and how you run the engagement
now but
the quality of this report reporting
that's provided still in that service
it's so great we can still have us
have his input and his expertise so
no hesitation
okay i endorse all that comments and
um i think it's imperative we keep on
looking and upgrading
all of our water supplies because it's
very important um
in today's standards okay have we got
any more
speakers it's moved and seconded
all in favor passed
okay
now we're moving on to 5.3108
page 108 and it's um jared and
simon um
i'll just give a very brief introduction
um and then simon can take it and take
it away from there
uh look the um this
this is a really small report um
for an absolutely enormous uh piece of
work we
this is the three-year cycle that we
work in um
activity management plans uh a key plank
of our um as our
infrastructure strategy and our
long-term plan
they pretty much summarize um a lot of
the work
even these reports that are referred to
they are they are summary documents in
themselves of a lot of the work that
goes on
so um they are definitely a good
resource always a
very good go-to if you've got a question
on a scheme i'd always recommend having
a look at the activity management plan
you can get a good understanding and
overview
and it's where you get a bit of a look
into the machinery that we have
working away within our department
to make sure that we're giving customers
of today
the level of service that they um need
but also looking at the looking at the
financial
um sustainability of the system out into
the future and making sure that we
we're farsighted in all of our decision
making but i'll let
simon take it away
thanks jared um you've said most of what
i had planned to say so
my my introduction will be perhaps a
little bit briefer but um
as jared said they are important
documents and they're very good
reference documents um they will remain
in diligent um each iteration of them
will remain intelligent so they
they will remain as a reference for the
whole
period until they're next reviewed
in addition to what jared said the
reports this report includes a summary
of the future challenges for each major
activity
and perhaps not surprisingly the themes
that come out there are
climate change which is a thread running
through all of the activity areas
and also water the water reform
that's clearly a major challenge coming
up for the three waters area
they also include a snapshot of the
costs
comparing the 2018 costs with the draft
2021 costs
now those graphs they are a snapshot and
they will be subject to change
as the budgets get debated early next
year
[Music]
and in terms of the process the draft
amps
in their final form will come back to
council in february for
a formal approval and then subsequent to
that the
uh the final final ones will get adopted
by council in
june before the or as part of the ltp
adoption so any questions
okay no questions um i'll move the
recommendation
have we got a secondary
you can play the mirror um no i think
it's all straightforward so
i think for me
thank you simon for all your work thank
you appreciate it
no more speakers i'll put that all in
favor
against
right so now we go to page 142
edly terrace proposed partial stopping
and we've got
no since there's nobody else here i'll
jared
they'll take this one so really this is
um
look it's really relatively procedural
we need to get
a recommendation from the unr committee
so that we can go to the council to
initiate
the process of road stopping
we do have a legislative process
that we need to follow that requires
that formal approval
this is where fully in
support of progressing this as it
coordinates with the agreed development
plan for the area so
if the land is to develop
in the way that is set out in that plan
it's necessary to
have this road closure because it is a
public process so it does give people
the ability to have their input
into it so i'm happy to take any
questions
no questions i i
counseling you've
[Music]
pete's been sending nibble and i emails
worrying about
not so much the closure but then that
the name i think he's worried about
what his address is going to become in
the name of he said there's a rumor
he's heard that we're changing the name
of emily terrace which of course we're
not
but can are you are you guys in contact
with
with him um we should be
i won't i haven't personally been
involved in any of those discussions
but i will make sure that we follow that
up and go back and
uh go back to pete with him to just
confirm exactly uh what's going on there
oh we've got a mover
and we've got a second council award
it really is procedural well in terms of
practice
it does need to happen this now to make
this effective we've been through
um significant process with lyme and
others around us now so it's around just
confirming that and this is just
recommending that this now goes to the
council so
that's the recommendation so this will
be on the councillor junior on monday
if this is agreed by uh unr today
i'll put that all in favor i
past right we come to portfolio updates
um i've got myself first and there's not
really much to
um about here about flexton road with
um seem to have got a reasonably pretty
good
price on the um that um roading scenario
so um so apart from that there's not
really much for me to
talk about so we go to drainage and
stock water
well some significant things here um
we have finally been granted the um
uh waimakariri maintenance minor works
we have been granted the
long awaited maamakuri
maintenance and minor works consent for
drainage and stormwater works
it comes with a few because
uh because of the mps freshwater and nes
it comes with a few
um extra demands i guess
and that how i understand it and
probably
um talk to it is that individual and
stream works will require
it's not so much a consent or
notification or
what does ek now require as part of that
consent if we're doing in-stream
um work because it's not
sort of totally smooth running is it uh
no there are some
now there's some notifications that we
need to provide in advance just to
let them know and it's more consistent
with we have a consent for undertaking
spraying as well so we need to
notify them in advance of um locations
that we will be spraying so
um just now we've got to consent for our
maintenance works
and we need to notify them in advance of
any works we're doing in particular
areas so most of the time
we know the drains on an annual basis
that we do maintenance works within and
we can notify them well in advance
uh we just need to get in a a process in
place for any of the more reactive type
maintenance works that we do yes and it
also
enables now the cam river improvement
work
in stream and sediment trap stuff too
and bank
stuff to go ahead but because it's taken
such a long time
to get to this point with this consent
we're going to have to review that
program and um
i would like it to come back to land and
water so we can have a
another look at that in the in the new
year
um so that's that one um the other one
that kelly
um might also want to talk about is that
uh pond c on the um water treatment
pond on the flat sunflower side
corner is some breaching and breaches
over its consent and this council's
working with
with ecan about it we've also had uh
water zone members notice the
sediment that's flowing into the it's
not quite pristine but it certainly
has it hasn't got that sediment level um
in the
in the the waterway itself so it also us
perhaps kelly might like to update
the committee on on what's happening
there with that
consent and in the pond itself
sure so in terms of the non-compliance
report that we've received from the
regional council
the non-compliance relates to reporting
so provision of testing and inspection
results
so we are currently working with the
regional council in terms of
collating the information that we do
have available
and submitting that through
the other aspect that we're working with
the regional council on
is there has been some discussions
regarding our
application for our network discharge
consent for rangiora
and more recently the processing
officers have
suggested that pond c consent remains
separate to the ringing or network
discharge consent
now from our perspective we do not want
that because
the ponzi consent is probably one of our
most complex
consents it's got about 62 conditions
and some of them are so onerous that and
practically
that difficult to actually um
to actually give effect to so we
are going back to the regional council
and
seeking that it still is captured within
the rangiora network discharge consent
but that we identify identified as one
of our major
discharge points so that effectively
means that
at the ponzi discharge point there will
be additional frequency
as well as a range of contaminants that
we
actually test for we actually want to
make sure we do
have consistency across all of our
network discharge consents and don't end
up with
the regional council kind of picking and
choosing watson and what's out
so we've done a lot of work to make sure
we do
have conditions that capture everything
and we can actually just recognize
um if there are catchments discharge
points they've got particular concerns
with we can highlight them as a major
discharge point that we
focus on in a bit more detail so that
approach
is what we're using for kaya poi as well
and they have accepted that in kaiapoi
so we're hoping they'll accept that in
rangiora in terms of the murky water
so that has been an ongoing issue there
and we're using a two-prong approach
to address it first of all looking at
what works we can do within the pond
itself
um so there's been reports of
die off of plants in the past as well as
the
um the birds in the in the pond itself
just
stirring up and agitating any of the
sediment uh
we were hopeful that we would have been
able to do some
planting to improve some of the areas
that have died off
what we've actually found is that the uh
the water level in relation to the
ground level within the pond is
different to what was designed
um so we couldn't actually use the
plants we would thought we could use
we're actually
plants that were just on the margins so
we're actually looking at trying to
put in some plants that are more
suitable
suited for within the water itself um
and sophie is looking at doing a trial
relating
to that um also the planting is
looking to put in areas where just to
move ducks out of the area will make it
less likely that they'll be in that area
so
if there is any stirring up of sediment
occurring within the pond
that it doesn't make its way through to
the outlet itself
and the other prong that we're taking in
there is actually
working with the landowners in the
upstream catchment and making sure their
on-site practices
uh robust such that there's not a
high amount of sediment loading into the
pond one of the challenges that we have
is because a lot of the catchment area
is graveled
you get that finest sediment that you do
coming off
gravel that's put in um to those areas
and that usually happens for maybe the
first two to five years
and then the you know that that gets
washed off but then we've got the
problem of it being in our pond as well
so it's a two-prong approach what can we
do within the pond itself
and what can we do with landowners in
terms of their on-site practices
thank you got a question from council
blackie actually
um the in definition of in-stream work
um
and does that does that apply to streams
and drains
both and what are you defining as
in-stream
work like if a branch falls into a tree
uh it
falls into a creek um on a farm is the
farmer going to have to notify ecan to
to take it out is that in-stream work as
michael
whipped in to do a minor maintenance is
that is that
going to have to or is it i mean is the
paperwork going to be overwhelming
um i hope that it will not be
um and there's probably still a degree
of
um bidding in to find out um
you know what is actually going to need
to be notified um
it's not intended to capture private
work at the moment
although if there is certain type of
private work
being undertaken we've already signaled
that there will be a mechanism for them
to
um via the council undertake the works
under our consent
but effectively it's only going to be
works where
um you know the bed is it the bed itself
is actually being disturbed so the
example you gave
of you know vegetation falling into
a waterway needing to be removed
wouldn't need to be notified under the
consent
hopefully yeah
i just find this a bit crazy that you've
got to try and
remove bird life from a water
source i mean what part of do they not
understand
birds go to water and and they don't
care which where they go to yeah
but but you're never going to stop them
from going in there
you you're right you're not going to
stop it but as part of
how we design our stormwater management
areas knowing that birds are going to
come into these areas we need to make
sure
that they don't particularly where the
water zone is if it's quite shallow
that's where because you can have birds
in there that's when you know
if it's shallow they are going to
disturb the base of the pond so
the design and the operation of the pond
is important
um to make sure that any bird's wildlife
that's in there
is not going to stir up any silt so
you're not going to stop it but you can
actually
through how you design and operate it
minimize the effects of the wildlife
coming into the area
um
yes i guess an
urban rural interaction
about who is contributing most to
maybe contamination of our streams the
zone committee is particularly
focused on on
unless you've got any more questions
i'll just move on to the other thing in
my update which is
um that um because of the
nps freshwater and nes and the
implications for um operating
uh drainage network and any work we're
doing
particularly in the rural area
i've suggested that we have a combined
rural groups the drainage
the rural drainage groups meeting next
year where
the council can explain what the new
regulations require
and also talk about the council's
approach to um to fulfilling what those
regulations
require because as you've identified
or it may come clear to you that there
are restrictions
now on um a lot of
work that private owners may
want to do and won't be able to do
uh and and the council as can he has
said whether this network consent and
now enables them to come
in under the uh under the umbrella of
the council and you would appreciate
also that
any rehabilitation works that anyone
might want to do
to an area um a waterway
has now requirements that
we may need to in fact uh sponsor
work under our consent because it's
taken five years
effectively from where to go to get this
consent
and the imposition on private landos is
to do
you know rehabilitation work in these
streams is enormous
so having uh and
in addition the natural waterways
requirements which have
have the drainage um
staff have already um hit with
landowner pushback and just how the
council is going to approach
all that under this new mps so early in
the new year
a young a combined
rural drainage group meeting that i
think everybody
um certainly on this committee should
have an invite to
come along because they are significant
changes
and we're going to get um we're going to
be at the forefront of
of getting pushback from landowners
thank you report for myself on
utilities and waters and we've just had
the
final sort of um for the year meeting at
points road and everything seems to be
going quite good
everybody came out of the meeting very
very happy which was
um might have been a wee bit of a
surprise to
kelly and um colin but um i think we
the way it was presented has been
actually brilliant so um
um all the parties who seem to be quite
happy on there
i'm particularly happy with um the way
colin and their staff did pro-action
with the
waikoku when they heard a wee bit of
rumor on
um local media that there may have been
some bugs around the area of the water
supply so getting under that
very quickly was um you know taking the
extra sampling and all that was
um i was quite impressed with that so um
like to thank
the staff for organizing that um that's
it for me on it
um solid waste counselor brian's not
here so we've got nothing there so we've
got
um i'll let kelly answer that one
it's uh so uh
in terms of the funding approach you
that will be
at the end of january as part of
deliberations uh well sorry
as part of the draft um yes so
that's part of the stimulus package to
agree in terms of the
uh 168 000 to be addressed
um so that will be end of january that
council will consider that
um the our next steps are to write
regarding the other outstanding issue
which is the remaining 12
19 unit connections on the scheme
so we are writing to them
and at the meeting last week
earlier this week earlier this week at
the point through meeting earlier this
week
they endorsed a approach where
we will write to the 12 19 unit land
owners
and uh say that they
uh need to look at reducing down the
units from 19 down to at least eight
or less and that the um
the right to the um to the units will be
grandfathered um so if they if they do
develop their property
then um they will be entitled to the
units without paying a dc
um but that right will effectively
cease when the property is sold so it
only remains with the existing
property owner so we uh
um we have signaled that depending on
where that lands
might actually alter rates um slightly
so if all of those 12 go down to two
units
um then that is going to change what
we're predicting at the moment we're
effectively
assuming that those remaining 12 will go
down to eight
um so that's that's the next step
um and the outcome of that will be
um reported through to unr i understand
you and my apologies i've just found a
wee note there is an apology from
councillor brian today so if we can
include that and apologies
um the solid mace i just like to bring
up something
on behalf of robbie um
for the recycling we're getting a lot of
um flaking all that everybody going
through it is actually starting to
improve
um there have been quite a few bins
apparently that have been rejected and
they've never been put out since so
they're
they're keeping an eye on those so
they're waiting for them to reappear so
i think
we have four collections past some of
these people
so far and their bins haven't come back
out again so
they are keeping an eye idea um an eye
on that and see what happens
right we'll go to transport got mia dan
gordon
thanks well a lot of the um well
firstly really pleased that the northern
corridors open and thanks for those who
are able to
join the opening onset i thought it was
really um a really good opening actually
and it was nice
that night to hariri joined us
at that particular opening got a few
lines away to the minister as some of
you will know around the william bypass
so
looking forward to assad turning at some
stage
we had a meeting with the minister after
with the greater christchurch partners
to discuss
transport issues more broadly for
canterbury including
all the options we've been working
through around modeshift and those
others it's very clear that the
government's priority will be around
decarbonisation and so any plan that's
put forward
around writing is going to need to meet
that criteria we've got a bit of work
there's a partnership to do in that
space but i think it was a really good
start
to the show that we're joined up that we
are actually thinking about those things
and that um certainly in my
i invited the minister to come back on a
regular
cycle to meet because it's really
important that we do and
and he seemed open to doing that so
transport issues for for not only our
district but also for
uh greater christchurch area and
canterbury are really important
there is going to be um as part of the
mural forum
there's going to be a visit to the ports
airport
and to timuru to see how transport
functions
operate that'll happen in february and
an invitation has been extended to the
minister if you would like to join that
visit and that's to see how all those
modes are operating
i'm really encouraged with kiwi rail
they've reached out a number of times
now
sitting around the level crossing
incident but are keen to build a closer
relationship with our council and it
follows on from a conversation that at
uh
um zone five and six when they presented
that was a good presentation i spoke to
the
to the representative after that our
engagement with nzta is not team zta but
with kiwi role hasn't
always been as positive as it could be
and and like i mean not not in terms of
our staff yet
but in terms of the amenity things that
we want to see improve like
um here in rangiora where there's level
for example the level crossing
and the community's uh desire and
to to see that improved and to work on
that
they haven't always been forthcoming or
helpful it's very clear that that
is um with this gentleman's appointment
i can't remember his name it'll come to
me in a minute
uh he's really keen to um and he's got
the directive that there to build a much
better relationship
so that's positive um from that side and
he wants to meet in the new year so
that's really good
um lots of things going on in the
transport space i don't need to tell you
because you're will know about those but
i just like to acknowledge
um uh paul as the voting portfolio
holder we meet
regularly with um jared uh
joanne and carl and to try and keep on
top of
the things that are important in our
area and
i'm really appreciative of how
responsive our staff are
in turning around where we have
issues raised and so so i personally
find that a really good
working relationship so that could be
passed on to the staff
jared appreciation for how they're
working and
with a really high workload in that area
as we all know
we're all amateur rating engineers we
all have opinions in that space
managing that's always um a bit of a
challenge but i think
personally our roading staff are really
stepping up as
is the contractor and cycon
and really want to see an improved level
of service so
that's as good as we go into the new
year that we've started the year i think
on a
bit of a positive it's not a positive
that we've had the number of road
fatalities that we have
ahead and it's a real concern um
don't know quite what the driver for
that is but obviously there's a lot of
stress
all sorts of factors going on at the
moment and
obviously people just need to take their
care out there on our roads because
we don't want to see that a continuing
trend it's not it's not something we
want to see at all
thanks team and we've got a
yes yes
um
is
um sorry which one did you mention
outside
oh yes yeah yeah sure yeah um so yeah we
do we do have some shelters in stock
um that we are hoping to roll out this
before the end of the financial year um
we do need to do some prioritization
around where they
go based and we normally base it on
patronage obviously taking into account
some of our new stops though
but there is a large packet of package
of work around
to do with uh the travel demand
management business case that
is the wider canterbury work which has
allocated
quite a lot of funding or requested
quite a lot of funding for
bus stop improvements infrastructure
improvements
so that will be rolled out over the next
um
i'm looking at jared kushner's um yeah
no that's all right look
you will actually get some specific
commentary from
joanne in the ltp budget so there has
been that
traffic demand management piece of work
done at a regional
level and that puts a recommendation up
we've taken that recommendation and
considered it along with other
priorities
so there's an allocation that's
suggested
in that strategy and we've actually got
in our budgets that we've worked through
we do have
some figures in there going out over 10
years they don't
match the currently in the budget don't
match what those recommendations are
but we are actually um specifically
bringing
that to you so the council will have its
opportunity
to consider whether the level of funding
that staff
have proposed is in line with what your
expectations are or whether you wish to
resolve something different we have i'm
pretty sure in the first year we've
taken a bit of a pause because
it actually takes kathy quite a lot of
time to get some of these
things set up um and uh but then from
year two onwards
that uh there's um an annual
budget allowance in the ltp
it's it's to come it has been discussed
in fact when we go down there in
february we're going to
but there has been uh certainly it was
raised
the other day around the desire to see
that child
further um but
we'll just see there's not a response to
that cathy on the
charles upham site from my point of view
um you don't have to
i would i would see that as a priority
to get a bus
covered stop down there with the number
of residents that there are
and also
yes but it would be it is a priority for
me
i would i guess others will need to
consider that but
it would be a priority to see shade also
every time i go to charles up on my mast
around the bus service
and uh and there so they they do want to
use it which is great
yes and i would just say it's probably
an easier one to get a shelter in
because there's no immediate neighbours
and
as you know we have to go through a
process people can object
to a shelter and we have to have a
hearing so um certainly one you know it
is on the list
thank you i've got a bit of an update
from herod
thank you this is my portfolio update
thank you mr chair
look i um i thought i'll just take a
moment if you please bear with me
um just it's been an exceptional year
very
unprecedented and i just want to firstly
acknowledge the support of the utilities
and writing committee for staff
and and in the broader council we've had
to
be very adaptable throughout the year
and it's been really good to know that
we've been able to make the decisions
that we have with the support of our
elected members
but mostly i'm actually i just want to
acknowledge the staff within the union
our department
and i will go through a list i just
top of mind listed a whole pile of
things that we've actually
that have happened this year that we've
done this year um that are
over and above our what we had planned
to do when we started the year or what
we do in a normal
year so we've established the trade
services panel
um which goes a long way i think in
terms of our
procurement um just the way everyone got
up and worked so productively from home
with covert we were
one day we were in the office working at
100 the next day everyone was at home
working at 100
and it didn't it didn't slow down um
we managed the staff managed our
contracts successfully and i think
um we were again stood out amongst other
councils
contractors we were proactive um
variation claims were fair and managed
whereas i think
other entities who might not have been
so on to it
probably expose themselves to quite
substantial claims from contractors
we kept all our essential services going
through the covert shutdown phases
the solid waste service contracts in
terms of all of the communications
through
the various levels and then again
the contamination issue that we've had
touch wood we've got a 10 million dollar
plus
roading capex program that we're
actually on track to deliver and that
some of those have been really really
challenging to get to the point we've
got there
we secured nine million dollars of
government funding for shovel
ready for the community we've geared up
and we've got a program in place to
deliver that
subdivision workload has just really
ramped up
recently we've actually been
through quite a few iterations of the uh
budget so you'll recall
we had to actually re look at our annual
plan budgets
to respond to the economic impact of
covert and then again at the moment
we're going through
a lot of work on the ltp budgets to try
and deliver you something that's going
to be
acceptable to the community you saw the
activity management's plans come through
today that's a one and a three year
part of the cycle
we also are initiating the 10.3 million
dollar
water stimulus funding from the
government oh well
nine million of that is from the
government um
the uh and actually getting together
this
there's been a lot of work from staff to
bring
the council a um a program of work
with an equitable funding um allocation
that we thought was going to be
acceptable to elected members in the in
the community
um which also includes consideration
development contributions
the three waters the information request
we're doing at the moment
um we're on on program to deliver that
just to give you an idea there's 67
worksheets excel worksheets involved in
that over a thousand questions
and we've just yesterday been identified
by lg nz
as one of a small handful of councils to
be star performers
in terms of the progress on that rfi
workbook as well as the quality
and comprehensiveness of the data
entered retaining our double a
rating that excellence program has got a
large
focus on the services within unr and
eric's sc management
i know i do acknowledge it's a full
council thing but that was a that was a
great achievement this year
we successfully attended and awarded the
road maintenance contract
and we're on program to deliver our last
water supply
upgrade to the drinking water standards
which again is an exception
um and you would have seen an email i
sent about the amis project so i just
really want to acknowledge the
staff within my department they've
worked really hard this year
and um i think it's worth a comment on
that
thank you i just i i would
just and others may wish to comment jury
but that's an amazing
level of achievements you and the team
and we
are working extremely hard and i know
there's a number of staff working
exceptionally long hours and are really
i think looking forward to christmas as
a number of us are actually this year
but right across our organisation it's
just the amazing new workload that's
been done
in a number a lot of it during the
lockdown period so
your leadership of the team is is
phenomenal
and the workload that's going on there
um deserves our full thanks
um this week jim and i did send the
other communication to staff to thank
them for their contribution and
as we had discussed uh have awarded a
day's
an additional days leave to just
recognize
all those achievements that are being
undertaken the lgep
excellence program which you know in
itself
is a major feat plus all that extra
workload it was
just just a small way of recognizing
from us our thanks for all that work so
please pass on to your team now thanks
because um
doing exceptional work
yeah and um i'd like to um endorse
um all the things to the from my
portfolio um
members have been keeping me um informed
all the time
sometimes very much after hours
and um it's been appreciated to be kept
up to date with everything so
thank you
um so i greatly admire all the hard work
and
seeing the hard work and the challenges
that
you've actually accepted and the
humongous
workload i have to say and the finished
result
a lot of people have commented to me
about the surface of ivory street that's
just been completed
and how people are now actually using
that excess way out
and are very appreciative of the fine
surface
that's been done to um finish off that
project
as well as i think it was another one is
it down john's road somewhere down there
as well people have commented
it's all right no it's um it's lovely to
see the
the great improvement and and um
after you know when we've developed
um the final plans and to see it
finished and see it working really
really well is really satisfying so
big thank you but um and um jared
and kelly and all your team you know
we admire you greatly thank you have a
happy christmas
okay all right so
councilman
thank you very much i really appreciate
everything that's been done
um i'm sorry i'm actually not on the
committee anymore but i really
appreciate
the workload that's that's been um with
you
and i just like to say from that points
road
meeting the other day i that the shift
and
change and attitude for the staff was
abs
not because of the staff but because of
the committee
that were quite negative and and um
aggressive over things
to have them like quite so mellow as
they have was a huge and it was just
really thanks very much
to the staff that that it was achieved
it was incredible
and and for that it will go forward and
be a well-established water
body it works great okay
right so we've got um no questions
understanding orders no urge with
general princess so we'll
move into somebody to move
and the public excluded